بعد انتظار لنحو ثلاث سنوات انتزع عياد
وزوجته حنان حقهما في استرجاع اموالهما
بالدولار لدى احد المصارف اللبنانيه فقد
اصدر القضاء حكما بتسديد وديعتيهما نقدا
وليس بموجب شك مصرفي لتجري حنان عمليه
جراحيه ويساعد عياد شقيقه المريض ذلك ان
المصرف متوقف عن دفع الدولارات منذ بدايه
الازمه الماليه لكن العبره في التنفيذ
لاني الموضوع الموضوع بالنسبه لاي حدا هو
موضوع ممكن يكون سهل بس بالنسبه للي ايده
في النار
حطموا حياتي كامله انا بتنتهك حقوقك
كانسان
هذا الحكم القضائي الذي وصف بغير المسبوق
دفع مدعينا كثرا لتجديد احتجاجاتهم
والمطالبه بودائعهم المحتجزه لدى المصارف
واستطبع بتوقف المصارف عن العمل اعتراضا
على ما وصفته بتعسف القضاء المصارف عم
تكذب على الناس سرقت مصريات
ومن شان هذا القرار ان يؤجج السجل بين
المصاريف والمودعين صدور هكذا قرار على
مستوى محكمه التمييز قد اثار رده فعل قصوى
من قبل المصارف مخافه ان تذهب المحاكم هذا
الاتجاه ويكرس اعتبار ان الشيك ليس وسيله
ابراء
وتقول المصارف انها غير قادره على اعاده
جميع الودائع بالدولار لانها اقرضت المال
بموجب القانون للمصرف المركزي الذي اقرضه
بدوره للحكومه ولبنان متوقف عن سداد ديونه
منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
بالمعايير المحاسن المحاسبيه الدوليه
ووفقا لمعايير بازل بنوك لبنان مفلسه ولكن
عايشينها حاليا لدينا ما يلاقوا اعاده
هيكلي ويلاقوا صيغه لتوزيع الخسائر بين
البنوك والدوله
جانب اخر من الازمه يتمثل في رفض بعض
المصارف رفع السريه المصرفيه عن حساباتها
وحسابات اعضاء مجالس اداراتها في اطار
تحقيقات بتهريد اموال بسبب ما تصفه
بالتباسات قانونيه وما تل ذلك من ادعاء
على هذه المصارف بتهمه تبييض الاموال
لرفضها التعاون
يتشعب الصراع اذا بين المصاريف والمودعين
الذين لجاوا الى القضاء بشان الودائع
بالدولار وتحقيقات في مسؤوليه المصارف عن
الانهيار المالي ملف ستنعكس تداعياته ليس
فقط على مستقبل عمل المصارف بل ايضا على
كيفيه تنفيذ خطط الانقاذ المالي
جونيوس الجزيره بيروت